سيكون الجو حارًا كما عرفت باسم
الطباخ الأعمى الذي نشأت في هيوستن وما زلت
أعيش في هيوستن. أحب المدينة ، لذلك أنا
متحمس لافتتاح أول
مطعم لي هناك ،
سأطلق على الماعز العمياء
حانة فيتنامية حديثة  حيث أتناول
الكثير من أطعمة الشوارع الأقل شهرة في
فيتنام وأضع قصتي الشخصية
في الأطباق أيضًا ، وبدأت في
الطهي عندما كنت في الكلية لأنها
نابعة من عدم
طهي منزل أمي وفقدان البصر
تدريجيًا  الوقت لذلك سأضطر دائمًا إلى إيجاد
طرق جديدة لتكييف الباب الذي يمكن فتحه
في مركز الحوض الخاص بي الذي تم
تشخيصه بشكل صحيح باستخدام nmo
باختصار في حالات المناعة الذاتية حيث
يؤثر بشكل أساسي على الأعصاب البصرية في
مدرسة خريج النخاع الشوكي كان عندما
قررت أن أجري تجربة أداء لـ MasterChef
للنساء اللائي لم أدرك أنني سأصل إلى
أبعد ما أفعل وأعتقد أن الباقي هو
التاريخ
كريستين كامرأة
كأمريكية آسيوية في مطبخ تجاري
يعاني من ضعف في الرؤية في بعض الأحيان
أشعر أن الناس لا يتوقعون مني نفس القدر ،
لكني وضعت 100٪ في كل
ما أفعله وأثبت للآخرين في
النهاية أن لديها المثابرة
والعزم على الاستمرار في تحدي
نفسها ووجهات نظر الآخرين
[موسيقى]